very much the organizers and to the
Institute for having me to last couple
of weeks I've really had a lot of fun
but today yeah what I want to do is
attempt to sketch a path by which we can
start from qubits and get all the way to
Einstein's equations and because of time
and because the fact that there are
technical details that still haven't
been worked out this is not a complete
program yet but I will hope to show you
that it's plausible that the concepts
are basically in place and to give you a
few concrete results that are really
important along the way so that's what I
want to do today so so what's what's the
motivation well we have gravity right in
the real world things fall down and and
more than that this gravity is actually
quantum mechanical it seems it didn't
have to be so perhaps but it seems to be
true the most basic argument for this
fact starts with the ultraviolet
catastrophe and electromagnetism which
people dealt with the beginning of the
last century in which you said I'll have
electromagnetic waves they have some
equilibrium distribution but that
equilibria distribution has a divergent
energy all right but that might put
Planck's constant in there then that
regulates that divergence and I get
something finite and so in fact people
have measured Planck's constant in a
sense they had measured what's called
the stefan-boltzmann constant which was
essentially Planck's constant you know
at though you know in the in the
previous previous century in the 19th
century it was already known but there's
no really crucial conceptual difference
between electromagnetic waves and
gravitational waves so a similar
argument would suggest that
gravitational waves which we know exist
at least indirectly also can feel h-bar
maybe more direct to recent evidence
would be for example this recent
fantastic measurement from bicep2 that
you may have heard about where they have
observed in the sky angular fluctuations
which are
your thumb is like about about a degree
the moon is half a degree so they see
multiple degree fluctuations in the sky
which are supposed to be primordial
quantum gravitational fluctuations that
have been amplified by inflation so it's
only a statement you can see in doing a
few degrees in the sky you can see the
effects of quantum gravity that's that's
one of the implications of the most
direct reading of the recent experiments
of bicep2 so so so really quantum
gravity is a real thing it's not just a
theorist toy it exists in nature we like
to understand it and so for my purposes
what that means is I'd like to have a
hilbert space and a Hamiltonian so I
want to have kinematics and dynamics
right and it may be that quantum gravity
has some aspects of quantum mechanics
and not others so maybe this is not the
right ultimate goal but let's try this
goal and see how far we can get and then
once I give you the helpit space a very
important step will be to recover so
many classical physics yeah I will yes
yes but the hilbert space will not be a
local hilbert space in the same
dimension in which the gravity lives in
the semi-classical limit so there will
be something special you'll see it does
have a tensor product structure now this
tensor product XR corresponds with bulk
locality in the semi classical limit is
not necessarily obvious okay so this is
what I want to do and I think the goal
is indeed to tell you what the culprit
space is to tell you what the
Hamiltonian is and then to show you a
plausible route to getting this in a
classical physics out now let me give
you a few clues since this is a tensor
Network workshop and not a quantum
gravity workshop
let me give you some clues as to what
quantum gravity should look like the
first clue is the Hamiltonian is a
boundary term this is because you know
the mechanism I have a charge I have
some charge in a region I can measure
that charge at infinity by looking with
little test charges right so I can
measure the total charge and close in
some large system but in gravity that
charge is mass itself right so I can
measure the total mass of a system by
looking at infinity yet the affects of
little test particles moving in
essentially the Newtonian gravitational
field of that total mass but because
mass is itself energy then this means
the Hamiltonian is itself observable
from infinity so the Hamiltonian is
really a property of the asymptotics of
the space in some precise sense yes so
where I'm really thinking in this case
about Minkowski space but for a closed
University at something like the energy
is zero basically just on the same since
there's no you can have no net charge in
a closed space right field lines up to
end somewhere so that's one clue the
second comes from black holes very
famously black holes can be associated
entropy which behaves very much like
thermodynamic entropy and this entropy
is related to a geometrical property of
the black hole which is the area of the
event horizon in some units which we
call Planck units so this is Newton's
constant and there's various H bars and
C's that have been put to one okay so
this just did this this told us the
Hamiltonian was really some kind of
boundary term this suggests the hilbert
space has a very peculiar structure when
gravity gets strong that the degrees of
freedom don't live in volume they live
on surfaces which is again similar to
what we saw in the Hamiltonian case and
the third clue is what I'll call well
let's just say it's gravitational
redshift
which says the following if I had a star
here of some mass m and I started out
with a little atom here which emits a
photon to infinity so this is R and this
is R equals infinity then the frequency
that I would observe at infinity is the
frequency that I would produce at R
times a factor which is interprete
Balazs a gravitational redshift that is
the photon has to climb out of the
gravitational well and so it loses some
energy and so in this sense going back
to this point one if I look at infinity
at energy then the energy of a photon
deep inside the bulk when viewed at
infinity is very low right so somehow
going inside the bulk away from the
boundary means going to low energies
sorry yeah that this is this is a spirit
electric star if some mass so this just
follows from the Schwartzel geometry and
in fact if you expand this out you'll
see that it's omega R one minus g-m over
RC squared this is this is the Newtonian
potential so it's just thing I have my
original mass minus the gravitational
energy and that's equal to the energy at
infinity okay so these are the clues and
the buzzword that goes with these clues
is to say that gravity is holographic
quantum gravity
it's holographic well it this is really
a shame about the first two but the
third is a clue about what the radial
direction means is that it's associated
with different energies the same
excitation the same photon emitted
different places corresponds to
different boundary energies so so the
first to say that the metric I mean
either that the Hamiltonian in this
hilbert space or somehow Ariat area'd
things and the last one tells you how to
interpret the radial direction as energy
scale in the boundary
so for the black hole yes I think the
last point of our interesting soda but
the only way out of a black hole no
that's right yes well no so it's a good
question and and the real issue is how
to interpret let's say in this black
hole commercial black hole the
asymptotics are not a dsm products
they're Binkowski asymptotics so that's
how things look different
the atham products are null instead of
time like so this is maybe let's just
say it's a motivation at this point and
then in the 80s case it will become
quite precise right so what I want to do
is so what what this tells you is that
whatever quantum gravity is a dependence
will be on the boundary conditions so
I'm going to consider a particular kind
of boundary condition where the boundary
is timelike which roughly means that
time survives at the edge so that so
it's not like it's not like the space at
infinite future or some kind of null
light light thing so I can write a
metric which looks like this this is
this R is called the 80s radius and
introduce some coordinates R T and X
which may be a vector and the picture is
like this I have X I have R and T comes
out of the board and the boundary R
equals 0 is the boundary and this is the
bulk
and this is the kind of faith I'm going
to ultimately this is a preview
basically at this point this is kind of
space I'm going to address where time
survives the edge and corn gravity is
easiest in this case precisely for that
reason that time survives of the edge so
I have to do less work instead of having
to produce both time and space I don't
have to produce space which is a simpler
task and although this this toy model is
not describing our universe as far as we
know quantum gravity is officially
complicated beasts that it makes sense
to understand this toy model completely
and then see if we can move on to some
other kind of asymptotics so what I'd
like to do is no you shouldn't and this
is this is related to this point that
time runs slower the far down you go so
this is this is precisely this this
gravitational redshift so I'm gonna
start in metal which is to sell you a an
intermediate point which will kind of
take a break at in the path from qubits
to dine Stein's equations and that is
going to involve entanglement in some
way that's the key ingredient here so
the start in the middle is I'm going to
assume that I have some some CFT and why
is it CFD because the symmetries of the
CFD I realized that I symmetries at this
metric so for example the scaling
symmetry where X goes to land X and he
goes to embassy are implemented when R
goes to lambda R and that's an isometry
of this metric okay so that's why that's
the FT enters the story
Oh in the CFT I well I mean I can create
excited states of some energy but yes
all the other elementary excitations if
you like are massless in the CFT but
that's different in the bulk they'll be
massive ok so I have a CF t and the
claim isn't the hilbert space of the CF
t equals the hilbert space of quantum
gravity this is all the SANS claim also
called ATS CFD and it has great
properties I assume that I'm going to
assume that I have a smooth
semi-classical geometry and I have some
entanglement structure which helps us to
find a minute and the basic
correspondence is that I have some state
of the CFT and it's just literally
equivalent to some data in the bulk
which will be some geometry G which is
the metric and some state of bulk fields
and these bulk fields include things
like the graviton if you have a
conserved current in the CFT it would
include a gauge field in the bulk can
include other kinds of fields and to
compute entanglement in these states
what I do is I do the famous for you
tucking ie formula or really just this
black hole formula again so it looks
like this so a is a region in the
boundary a tilde is a minimal surface
with respect to G this metric in the
bulk and Sigma is the interior and again
this is all at fixed time and the
fundamental assumption will be that the
integrant entropy of a in the CFT state
is equal to
the area of a tilde this extremal this
minimal surface in this geometry in some
units plus an extra term which is the
entangled entropy of the bulk degrees of
freedom in their bulk state right so
this is this is the this is what I'm
gonna assume okay for the second part of
the talk I'll assume this and so the
structure is gonna be I'm gonna start
from qubits let's call this star I'm
gonna go to star and then I'm gonna go
tine Stein this is the path and to go
from qubits to star I'm gonna use pincer
networks and to go from here I'm going
to use geometry and quantum field theory
in curved space and this part is done
with with Mark Van Ram stunk
okay that's the plan and so this is this
is kind of the the fulcrum in which the
whole argument is gonna hinge so first I
want to make this plausible using tensor
networks and then I want to use this to
get ya so let's enjoying the one
dimension so hazel is a interval right
and I say that the entire interview of
the a in the CFT state so this is just
CF t side can be evaluate on the gravity
side but looking at this minimal surface
calculating its area with some pre
factor and then containing time entropy
of the bulk fields so this is this is my
assumption ya know I'm really working
with this ADF geometry here yes X is
like the field theory direction and then
R is down well so I am assuming this
tutorial is true for all states or for
some class of states let's say some
class of semi classical States no they
could be time dependent but but how
mostly well use my argument is only the
ground state and small perturbations
from the ground state that's all I
really use but in principle like I think
I could assume that what I want to do is
assume this is true for some fun class
of semi classical States this will be
important ok yes it's it's uh bleeding
if you would think of G Newton as being
very small so that you have sort of semi
classical
well it could yeah it could be area but
it could also have like long-range
pieces long-range entanglement right so
like this could be you know could be a
topological State so it has an extra -
log - or some in principle it could mix
oh this is an important issue about how
to regulate this thing in the bulk
because this area contribution typically
is associated with UV physics so there's
a sense in which we can take this area
piece and move it over here and that's
defines the Low Energy Newton's constant
and some are normalized Theory so
there's a whole story told most recently
by Cooperman and Lu D which talks about
how to think about normalizing this in
terms of some effective gravitational
piece but I won't actually I won't
actually evaluate this how only evaluate
changes in it yeah that's what roughly
you should use thing at this term
internets I want to derive this later
it'll just be some kind of really global
stuff it's just some global entanglement
I put if I put a you know a qubit here
in a qubit there they don't be a log -
you know they were in some singlet yeah
well this is generalization which says I
should find some extremal surface right
and that's that formula is not
necessarily known to be correct so but
here I won't I'll just apply it the
stationary solutions and small
deformations thereof so it's I think
okay in that case it's just my
assumption I'm not actually driving this
you can derive it but it's I'm just
assuming it or I will drive it from some
different way yeah yes so it includes
the graviton at least because you have
some geometry but yeah you have some
skater fields or whatever in the bulk
it's just those matter degrees of
freedom sorry yes yes
okay so let me do part one which is cube
it's just start okay so for part one
okay I start with qubits they are my
qubits okay it's a random and a
one-dimensional ion they have some local
Hamiltonian H local but I want to be in
a special case I don't just want to
treat general situation because I don't
expect that I have send me classical
physics in the most general possible
case I want to be in some special limits
where gravity looks semi classical and
so that limit is is where the easiest
thing to do is where this is at a
critical point so I have some kind of
scale and grains I have a CF t in fact
and the local dimension is large and
some parameter so let's say in each site
there are many qubits and I arrange them
in this one-dimensional Y and these many
qubits interact strongly in some
unspecified way but so the total
Hamiltonian which is local is a critical
Hamiltonian and the fact that it's
critical at the CFT suggest that we take
this RG perspective and so what we want
to do is use Mir so I'm not gonna
justify this any more than to say you
would it's sort of a reasonable thing to
do you can you can you can justify it
better but that's previous talks I'd
given so in order to get dine sense
equations we have to assume something so
let's let's just assume that Mira is a
reasonable description based on ideas
ever normalization and various other
words so the way Mira works in this
language is you have some local degrees
of freedom you want
remove some entanglement and then you
want to coarse grain or throwaway states
that have become an entangled with the
rest of the system
like this and then I can continue
Emily if all these picture one time so
it doesn't take forever oh sorry
so I have some pictures so I've just
shown you a chunk of the network here
and itself similar right I remove
entanglements then I kind of factor out
degrees of freedom there and move more
entanglement at longer scale and factor
out degrees of freedom and I argued that
this network already reproduces much of
the geometry the spatial geometry of
this metric but in a discreet setting so
for example if you go down to link scale
to a or 4a or you know na where a is a
lot of spacing then you see it distance
has now become smaller I can go closer I
think I can get between two points much
faster down here because these tensors
go very much longer distance so you can
you know make various concrete
statements that for example the geometry
of this graph with some graph metric on
it so I'm just just some simple nearest
neighbor metric reproduces you know
sample G of Music's of this metric in a
nice way you can also show that the
graph laplacian has the same eigen
values at low energy at low eigen value
is the whole Posse on this space so
there's very things you can do to make
this more plausible yeah so this is
really the state so T is not obvious
here you can figure out what what the
metric component GDP is by looking at
the renormalization of the Hamiltonian
so if I apply the Hamiltonian up here
and then I move it through the network
you'll be ran Orma lies by a certain
factor and that factor can let me can
sort of let me figure out that this is
gonna be R squared here but time is not
explicit in this in this construction I
have to sort of infer it from some other
information yeah
sorry which yes you mean which which one
I you know whether I do this here or
there yeah you have to make a choice so
I mean with that choice may be an
artifact of the network I mean if it
what we what we would want to demand is
that this network is approximately or
exactly translation right so that will
be true for some special choices of
these tensors which you could enforce by
a rewiring invariance so you could you
know you could redo this network in a
different way to get the same answer so
in some cases we know how to impose that
condition exactly to prove the network
even though you make a choice the
network is actually translation right
okay so what about entanglement
so let me make some definitions the
causal cone which I write C C of a is
the set of all these tensors and sites
that can influence the state of a right
so it's all the degrees of freedom in a
network that can influence the state of
a I can also make another definition
which I call the shared causal cone of a
and B which is just a colorful cone of a
intersected with a causal cone of B so
this is all the things that can affect
both a ed Z then it's easy to show from
this network that's the most amount of
entropy that it can add or the entropy
that it adds is a property of just the
shared causal cone
of a and its complement right so in
other words all the tensors that connect
a to its environment and nothing else so
tensor is just within they call the cone
of a but not in the shared global cone
only affect a without affecting a bar
and suddenly the ones in a bar only
affect a bar so they don't change the
entropy right they can change the states
within the sub regions but they don't
change the entropy and because this
shared calls a cone basically looks like
this this is a a bar you can think of
the shared causal cone as being
essentially this surface roughly
speaking so this is how you can you know
in in words say that that that the
entropy is just a property of this curve
in the bulk and indeed you can say that
you can basically bound this like altmer
I call this a tilde you can bound the
entropy of throw a roughly speaking by
the size of a tilde times log Chi where
these tensors have legs of size sky
which you can think of as being this to
the
right and so in fact we can argue that
when this n is large you would expect
this bound to be saturated and that the
entropy becomes non fluctuating a
semi-classical the entropy added by the
network so this is the so-called large
and limits what can argue the bound is
saturated and we interpret this as some
kind of semi classical geometry non
fluctuating geometry right now it's
really just a graph geometry at this
point I'm not gonna do anything more
than that really I don't have time but
anyways it looks non fluctuating in it
in a certain precise sense want to have
many local degrees of freedom well it's
basically what I imagine is that these
these these tensors are kind of quasi
random so that they just always add a
large amount of entropy independent of
what states I put into them unless if I
put product states in let's say right
which is what I'm doing here
I take something here and I put our
product state and then I entangle them
so for product states our random unit
area is gonna entangle them a lot
irrespective of what products did I put
in so there's some argument about these
being generic tensors
okay so this looks sort of like the
first term of star right my fundamental
assumption where I said the entropy is
gonna be some kind of area term plus
bulk entanglement between degrees of
freedom in here and in here so I have at
least I hope made the first part of star
plausible or let me write star up here
again
so this term is sort of what we got here
okay now but what about the bulk of
degrees of freedom right so here is the
bounded degrees over here the bulk
degrees of freedom where and sometimes I
put them all into product states right
but I don't have to do that this is a
unitary transformation I can put them
into other states right so to get this
second term yeah yes so okay there's a
subtlety here which I don't actually
understand yet which there's a sense in
which maybe the second term is already
contained in this in this formula a
little bit like that the vacuum
fluctuations are already in here and
this describes the additional
entanglement top of the vacuum
fluctuations but I don't understand this
fully yet so so let me not say okay so
to do this I wanted to find one more
thing which is the reduced causal kind
of a relative to B which is the causal
cone of a - all the things that are in
the shared causal kind of a and B right
so this is all the things that that
really only impact a and can't affect B
or anything else and so you can show
that if I were to take bulk degrees of
freedom that is these zeros and change
them to something else right so now I
put you know five here and five prime
and so on
if I take both degrees of freedom and
the reduced causal cone of a relative to
its complement and entangle them with
bulk degrees of freedom and the
complements that reduce calls the
current element relative to a right so
this is all the stuff that can only
affect a and not possibly affect a bar
it's all the things that can only affect
a bar and not possibly up that day if
this is true then you can write the wave
function the ground list the state of a
as a sum in fact it's a direct sum of
probabilities times some states
associated with basically different
choices of bulk degrees of freedom so
this is really it's it sounds come may
be confusing but it's really a trivial
thing which just says that I'm basically
taking some product states and I'm
applying unitary strictly within a so
that obviously doesn't change the
entanglement it's like a local it's loc
see kind of operation right it doesn't
change the entanglement so I have a
decomposition like this and then s of
Rho a is sum over j QJ so it's the
average of the entropies of these states
right plus the Shannon entropy of the Q
yes
yeah these guys so just imagine I take
one of these guys and change it to Phi
and I change another one way over here
at the top layer to Phi Prime and I
entangle them in some way yeah these two
are entangled and all I'm doing is I'm
employing one short depth circuit and
that obviously doesn't change the angle
between these two things right because
they're far away they're outside I call
the contact yes yes exactly so these qjs
are really just the schmitt eigenvectors
of the original entangled state of these
both degrees of freedom yeah well so for
example this as I'm doing here so what
will happen is for example this bound
may not be saturated so it's not clear
that what if since you have a single
classical geometry and also this
separation of bulk bulk degrees of
freedom here and the tensors it has a it
has a nice sharp distinction this large
and limit in the sense that there are
they're sort of like this big classical
geometry and these little fluctuations
on top of it but more generally it sort
of everything is fluctuating equally and
it's not clear so basically some of the
some of the things just sort of are not
that's clearly interpreted I mean I can
still do the network for the Ising model
there's no problem and I can still do
this this this result is still true but
the interpretation is not as clear okay
and so these SRO AJ are all the same
because I'm just acting within nicole's
willkommen doesn't change the
entanglement so this is like a tilde and
this is like bulk entanglements
and you can see there's thirst there is
something nice about this in the sense
that I had to sort of stay away from the
edges between a and a bar in the bulk
right because when I act on when I act
on the edge that sort of it's not clear
does that belong to a or to a bar right
so there's a little bit of nonlocality
in the bulk and that's nicely reflected
in this formula and that this formula
only true when I only act within these
reduced causal codes okay so the point
is ultimately that I've obtained this
formula from the mirror network which
includes both some kind of area law
entanglement and also some kind of bulk
entanglement and it's an exact formula
there's no approximation it's just a
true statement about this network but it
looks a lot like stark so although I
don't have time to really fully justify
and if I can't fully justify the
equality of these two things I hope that
this at least makes it plausible this is
a reasonable place to start from if I
assume that this network geometry in
this limits becomes really smooth and if
I assume that this term here reduces to
the area term which it should in some
special case for some choice of dynamics
it should reduce and this is bulk
containment is easy to interpret then it
looks like I get that formula like this
just just to emphasize the elementary
nests of the starting point I think so I
mean I need to be more careful our
regulation but yeah I don't see what the
issue is
yes yeah I just want I want to emphasize
that that what's good about this is that
it's completely concrete it's put a ball
on a computer which is quite different
from quantum gravity normally but
normally there's Tula's and approximate
sand you know roughly Hilbert spaces and
this is really I mean it some things are
obscured by this like the symmetry of
Lorentz invariance for example but it's
completely concrete which is nice and
that's all this cubis was meant to
indicate that it's elementary is
starting from the bottom and it's and
it's concrete
okay part two so now we're gonna
completely switch gears I won't say
another word about tensor networks I'll
just talk about geometry starting from
this formula let's draw this favorite
picture again a a tilde sigma and the s
of a in the CFT state is equal to a
tilde
the area of a tilde plus the bulk
entanglement okay so now I want to start
from this I want with the assumption
that there is a geometry and so forth
and to show you that Einstein's
equations have to hold okay so it's so
again just remind you and I'm thinking
about I have a CFT state and this is the
same as some set of data which is a
metric some space time and some bulk
state and so to get dynamics this is
just an assumption about the way
entangled is encoded in States right
take it by nameks I need to consider our
variation all right so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to consider first of all
a variation of the CFT state and I'm
going to look for very technical reasons
at balls so a is a ball centered at X of
radius R and now I can work in I work in
D dimensions right so don't want it to
be one-dimensional and so what I can
look at and let me just mention at this
point that this this I'm gonna follow it
first some nice work by lashkar-e on
which mark that I'm stuck was also
involved by Falkner Bowl and then old
work by IR and Wald and they'll get us
part of the way and then I'll show you
I'll tell you where we have to introduce
but I'll tell you where this really this
extra term here really gets us all the
way ok so let's look at balls and let's
look at Delta s B so the change the
antenna interview of the ball under this
change of the state so if I'm very naive
this is just going to be Delta Rho B log
row B
that's some kind of naive perturbation
theory formula and it looks intact
except that actually I know what this
log Roby is for these balls in a car
home field theory I know that log Roby
has the following amazing form it's an
integral over B of a weighting factor
times the zero of the art component of
the of the CFD stress sensor that is the
energy density of the CFD with this
weighting factor ya integral over the
bulb so there there's a there's a DDX
here and I won't drive this formula for
you but I will tell you that it's
essentially a version of unrest
statements that accelerated particles
experience thermal radiation and in fact
this formula by itself is already
extremely useful just forgetting about
gravity just using this formula for CFDs
in particular because topological states
are also CFDs in the simplest case just
trivial CFDs right there topological so
in addition to not caring about the
decide that you don't throw out the
metric at all so you can apply the CFT I
mean the topological states as well and
prove the bulk edge correspondence for
example for any relativistic topological
State the bulk of course when has being
the statement that the entanglement
spectrum has the same Universal
properties as the physical edge spectrum
so this is a quite useful thing but it's
just for me a stepping stone which
allows me to derive a constraints on the
way that entropy changes are related to
changes in energy
RoR is the the radius of the ball and
our sub ATS is the ATS radius but I
won't really use that okay so what we
have is what's called the first law
because if this row had been just a
thermal state then this will be the
first law of thermodynamics this Delta s
equals Delta e Delta s be equals Delta e
B where EB is to find some kind of weird
energy
like this so that is the definition of
EB
it's some weird weighted energy inside
region D okay so this is all CF t but
what about gravity
so I just rewrote it I just I just wrote
this formula as as this is a this is the
operator
EB and then I took sorry like yeah let
me I need to do so then if I put a delta
rho b this is the change in the
expectation value yeah it's a
hamiltonian it's just it's this this
energy up here yeah this is space it's a
subset of space in the CFT yeah it's the
interior of the bowl it's it's be sorry
I've put temperature to one or two to
two pi actually so there's a two pi I
missed actually this this two pi is
understandable but let me not talk about
it you ask me afterwards yes I know what
doesn't say my Hamiltonian is yeah so
what I'd like to do is just to talk to
the same quantity on the gravity side
and I'm running out of time so let me
try to be brief the first thing you can
look at is Delta let's see what I wanted
to say here yeah so let me first define
what I mean by variations so Delta G I
mean that the metric is now this 80s
radius over R squared D R squared minus
DT squared plus DX squared plus some
little perturbation
which just acts in the field three
directions so this is just a choice of
coordinates I can always put the metric
in this one and then also have some
Delta sie Volk this is the data which is
equivalent to Delta side CF t alright
because I told you there just exactly
equivalent and so I want to use the CFT
relationship to derive a constraint on
these two pieces of data yeah G is the
metric
so let me just do it or show you how it
works
so first let me say okay there's Delta s
grav geometrical part which is Delta
this is what I mean by this it's the
gravitational part of the entropy which
is geometrical which is a tilde area
okay so this variation you can calculate
it depends on two things that the
minimal surface changes and the metric
changes so because the mineral surface
was extremal that variation doesn't
matter right this is equal to zero so
this is actually equal to just the
change you're the metric so I can write
it as the integral over a tilde of
something I'll call Chi right it's just
some metric change of I weigh on the
surface a tilde now a remarkable thing
is that we can also figure out what this
part is here either using this first law
looking at very small regions or using
the journal holographic dictionary which
says that which says that delta T mu nu
CFT is proportional to H mu nu and are
those to zero okay so this this is part
of the so-called holographic dictionary
which relates observable on one side of
the other but it can also be derived
just from this relationship but looking
at small balls and this is something
that that that these guys did yeah
no I'm just doing it some semi-classical
change in the metric in the geometry
yeah it's not quantized in principle
this can include changes in the state
for the bulk gravitons so that's
possible but that that's that's encoded
in this part not in this part okay and
so this and using this you can figure
out that Delta e be evaluated
gravitationally is actually equal to the
integral over a of this same thing this
is a non-trivial fact just really due to
iron volt and there's a third fact which
is that the derivative of this thing Chi
which is actually out form the
differential form can be written in this
way it's minus two so let me explain
this this is a killing vector which
means it generates a symmetry of the
balke metric I can write it down for you
in a second this is the linearized
Einstein equation without matter and
this is a volume form
so this really means you take you know
to get this Delta to get it's to get
this it's the gravitational action time
Delta G a B so I'm not assuming the
equation of motion hold I'm just saying
that this is a true formula for this
object Chi which satisfies these two
properties yeah so W graph is the famous
Bank where this is the cosmological
constant and that's the reaching
curvature but now I need one more
ingredient which is the change in this
term here right I've gotten this bit of
the entropy on the gravity side and I
figured out what Delta EB is when I got
these sides but I need to calculate this
and so in fact you can show the
following if I look at Delta Sigma
again the variation here comes from two
sources the minimal this region Sigma
could change in the new geometry and
then the state can change but it turns
out you can show that this quantity is
also extremely respect to the exchange
in Sigma so that part drops out and this
is just equal to minus trace Delta Rho
Sigma log Rho Sigma but in something
which is quite analogous to this formula
for this special case of balls it turns
out that a tilde is a horizon it has a
very special property if I just what's
what's called the bifurcation surface of
a killing horizon okay and because of
that I actually know for especially the
same reason I can figure out what this
integrant californian is I can also
figure out what this bulk in penguin
Hamiltonian is and it's equal to the
following thing it's integral over Sigma
the minus sign
like this this is the same killing
vector here let me just tell you what
this vector is it's minus 2 PI over R
there's some formula which you can
figure out
so I'm just taking this this timeline
component here and you can see if I put
R to 0 I get back this thing that I had
over here so actually this this is the
time like a normal feeling vector on the
boundary and it's the asymptotic value
of this telling back to in the bulk okay
but this formula is crucial because
everything is exactly the same with what
appears up here so now the final
argument goes like this I know that zero
must equal Delta s be minus Delta e be
this is equal to integral over a tilde
of Chi minus integral over a of Chi plus
integral over Sigma of this particular
quantity so this is the geometrical part
of the change in the entropy this is the
energy the change in Delta e and this is
the the bulk state part but now I use
this nice fact that D Phi can be written
in this way say if this is equal to an
integral over Sigma right this is a a
tilde sigma so what I have here is a
complete integral around the boundary so
I can change them into an integral over
D Kai which is minus 2 C 0
it should be Delta changing that like
this and this is true for all the XR
it's true for all balls and so you can
use this to show at the integrand
Vantage's
but the integrand is the linearised
finds an equation couple to matter and
in particular you have the equivalence
principle which says that all matter all
a bulk matter energy coupled to the bulk
metric universally by its stress tensor
and nothing else
so the Crimmins principle comes out of
this assumption that all it matters is
the total entangled entropy of the bulk
fields that's actually equivalent to the
equivalence principle and now from here
you can do various things here I only
got zero zero you can also get the field
three directions by boost ink so you can
get mune you from boosting and then mu R
and R are our constraints which Express
the fight at the CFT part the cfd stress
tensor is traceless and conserved so i
get all the components of linearized
equations and in fact then there's a
there's a simple well-known argument
that lets you go from the linearized
equations with a non-linear equations
which says that now i have matter and
gravitational fields interacting they
can exchange energy in order to have a
global conserved energy in the bulk I
have to include some interactions I have
to continue dressing things up in fact
you can get in a way which I won't
specify you can get actual to the Han
linear equation by imposing bulk energy
conservation or covariance if you like
but let's just say from here I got the
linearized equation yes it would be a
sense equation with matter universally
coupled so what have I done I sort of
started in the middle with this formula
here and then I tried to argue that this
formula is plausible from a tensor
Network point of view for CFTs and then
i use this formula to rigorously show
that if this formula is true then the
linearized Einstein equations hold ok so
hopefully I convinced you that there is
some kind of plausible trajectory
starting from microscopic degrees of
freedom in a perfectly well-defined
system
to get all the way at the end of the day
to semi-classical Einstein equations in
an emergent holographic bulk and so yes
please recall would I mean for each yes
but when you're ready for it so the each
data such as follows from cemetery so I
don't need to a solve an equation to get
it well then you take that you can add
more stuff and turn this equation to do
utilize each yeah so it's like uh
the gravity is a leave on the boundary
the man currently in the bomb so
actually this is a this actual degree of
freedom of firefight fine it looks like
an additional degree freedom you're
putting a ball I don't know whether to
but the gravity is one of these fives
actually the graviton is one of this
this finds one of these states you can
put in there I see so I see some
seriously bolsa matter at the granite
countertop degree fitness and the
boundary safety just gave you some place
back on the idea
well so a gravity of the CFD is is
indeed related to the state yes maybe
s-video these the bad ones but no
they're always in passing potting ABS
part which doesn't fluctuate that's
that's the sense in which you know you
know they make an econ underneath you
have some manner conditions you specify
which I non fluctuate but in the bulk
everything is kind of very bright so
these are different from the ADF to the
corresponding because there looks like
all the debris or feeling on the
boundary but now have any panel degree
freedom in the bulk they're not
independent right this this this that's
amazing level in the mirror all the
vault degrees of you there's there's
there's just exactly tied to the Alabam
where L is the length of the chain
and the mirror is as a unitary
transformation which goes from those
Kiley L distributed in various ways in
the bulk to these vowels degrees of
freedom at the top the exactly
equivalent which is what should be true
and they should just be different
representations of exactly the same
velvet space I see so this fight do
benefit naturally either you just under
a degree fit them only all use the pork
you know fire fight crime only mob
together yeah I don't think I reuse them
together because I the funk from Lisa
integration looks like that there's a
eight killed a looks like when you use
them separately this is still the
gravitational stuff it's just each the
asymptotic value of it I see so the neat
part is really not on the bumpers are
still coming the bulk yeah you can think
of the limits a nice
we know about
yes so so I guess all these fields
they certainly do yeah but there's
another there's another possibility just
that this formula is not I mean it
doesn't have to have people them to be
the area it could be for example the
integral of over that area of curvatures
right so they're in high really gravity
then you this formula is not is not the
right money to replace this with what's
called the wall of entropy and then from
that you can actually repeat the whole
argument and derive Hydrabad of gravity
coupled to matter by positing a
different kind of yes they do a second
area which is the simplest in some kind
of derivative expansion but you can
consider more general things they wrote
a paper which was called anthropic
gravity in status was begging State Farm
Olive Oyl yes entropy and somehow
managed to derive an equation is this
somewhat related it's similar but it's
it's very close inserted I recommend
super up Jacobson where he says that
that - equations following and posing
some kind of thermodynamic like equation
at every point in local River horizon
so here what I'm doing is like that but
only for global horizons and so I have
to do a little bit you know you got
something different than what you got
but it's so weird